House Speaker Nancy Pelosi is slamming a
new effort to dismiss impeachment
charges against President Trump and
Republican plans to hold a Senate trial
without witnesses dismissing is a
cover-up if they want to go that route
again the senators who are thinking now
about voting for witnesses or not they
will have to be accountable Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell supports
dismissal which the president is
demanding Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill forced Nancy good morning so when
will this trial if that's still the word
for it happened well it could happen
later this week more likely sometime
next week because speaker Pelosi still
needs to transmit the articles of
impeachment from the house to the Senate
for the trial after a nearly month-long
delay she's going to be meeting with her
house Democratic caucus tomorrow to
discuss when she is going to name the
house impeachment managers they're the
ones who would hand-deliver the articles
to the Senate and essentially prosecute
the case there yesterday Pelosi defended
the her decision to hold up the article
saying that the delay did draw attention
to the importance of hearing from key
witnesses in the trial like former
national security advisor John Bolton
Democrats say Bolton and other witnesses
have first-hand knowledge of the
administration's dealings with Ukraine
and the pressure that was placed on that
nation but Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell is making no promises he says
that he is going to be following a
precedent set by the 1999 Clinton
impeachment trial where Square Senators
began hearing evidence from the
impeachment managers and the president's
lawyers before they made any decisions
about whether to hear from more
witnesses over this weekend however one
Republican senator Susan Collins of
Maine told a local newspaper that she's
actually going to be working with a
small group of her fellow Republicans to
ensure that witnesses do testify in this
upcoming trial Gale all right Nancy
thank you very much
you